bonsoir paul touvier finira ses jours en
prison pour crimes contre l'humanité
l'ancien collaborateurs des nazis
avaient réussi pendant 50 ans a échappé
à la justice
la justice l'a rattrapé et l'a condamné
à la réclusion à perpétuité sans
circonstances atténuantes pour
l'exécution de cet otage gif le 29 juin
44 à rillieux-la-pape éric masson saint
corneille comme sur ces images du
premier jour du procès son visage est
resté de marne
il est ce qui sera simplement quand les
gars de l'emmèneront un signe de la main
à sa famille la compagne de paul touvier
sort un bouquet à la main
la justice est passée cinq heures trente
de délibéré pour une décision sans
ambiguïté oui paul touvier a donné
instruction aide et assistance pour
l'exécution de cette juifs à
rillieux-la-pape en juin 44
oui c'est un crime contre l'humanité
parce qu'il s'inscrit dans le plan
d'extermination des nazis paul touvier
condamné à la réclusion criminelle à
perpétuité
dans la salle les parents des victimes
de rio sont restés silencieux
ils sont soulagés jusqu'au bout j'ai
appréhendé jusqu'à l'été arrive et c'est
dommage évidemment d'avoir attendu
cinquante ans pour arriver à ce résultat
vous savez dans l'histoire c'est
naturellement touvier mais y ai mis des
centaines de milliers de tout biais qui
ont été nécessaires à l'allemagne nazie
ok soit déporté à assassiner tous ces
gens en voilà un qui a été pris qui a
été condamné c'est une juste chez la
justice
j'en suis content tous ceux qui se sont
battus pour ça tous les avocats des
parties civiles toutes les familles des
victimes pensent pas beaucoup à lui mais
pense aux victimes aux sept victimes de
rieux comme elle pense aux 44 enfants
d'izieu parce que c'était le même combat
c'était les mêmes hommes
c'était la même ignominie c'était la
même idéologie et je crois que bon c'est
ça qui domine aujourd'hui on pense pas
tous liés on pense aux victimes
maintenant le combat judiciaire des
parties civiles jusqu'à ce jour de la
condamnation aura donc duré 21 ans et
pour elle comme pour ces manifestants
hier soir ce combat pour la mémoire ne
s'arrête pas à tous vielles
souhaiterions que les procès en cours
puisse arriver à leur terme
il n'y en a plus qu'un et le procès de
maurice papon et nous ne pouvons que
souhaiter que la justice est un rythme
un peu plus soutenu que celui que l'on
peut observer depuis dix ans l'avocat de
paul touvier lui a perdu la partie sauf
cassation touvier finira ses jours en
prison
au nom du peuple français les jurés ont
décidé que cinquante années n'avaient
pas effacer le crime du serviteur
français de l'état nazi
vous avez entendu dans ce reportage d'
eric lemasson le nom d'un autre français
inculpé de crimes contre l'humanité mais
dont le procès n'a jamais julio maurice
papon
l'ancien secrétaire général de la
préfecture de gironde est accusé d'avoir
organisé entre 42 et 44 l'arrestation et
la déportation de plusieurs centaines de
personnes et d'enfants l'instruction de
son dossier quasiment terminée et les
familles des victimes souhaitent qu'il
soit maintenant jugé caroline laudrin
depuis 11 ans maurice papon est inculpé
de crimes contre l'humanité depuis 11
ans il contre attaque et porte plainte
pour dénonciation calomnieuse
lui l'ancien ministre du budget sous
giscard d'estaing l'ancien secrétaire
général de la préfecture de gironde
entre 42 et 44 n'admettent pas les
accusations portées contre lui en 1981
documents administratifs à l'appui le
canard enchaîné l'accusent d'avoir
participé à l'arrestation et à la
déportation de 1690 juifs dans la région
de bordeaux
deux ans plus tard il est inculpé de
crimes contre l'humanité mais le dossier
papon embarrasse la justice la procédure
est annulée pour finalement déboucher
sur de nouvelles inculpations en 88 et
92 11 ans après le début de la procédure
l'un des avocats des familles juives
s'étonne dans ce procès de la lenteur de
la machine judiciaire la procédure est
terminé il y a vingt hommes
d'instruction dans la procédure papon
quelques on attend on doit s'arrêter à
l'heure actuelle de vouloir à toute
force entrer dans ce dossier des
procédures préalables concernant
bousquet le guet
noren berg et pourquoi pas tous les
procès d'après guerre comme celle de
pétain de laval
pourquoi pas le concept danemark comme
lorsque pierre arpaillange ancien garde
des sceaux et roland dumas ancien
ministre vienne témoigner au procès de
paul touvier ils ont un regret celui de
ne voir qu'un milicien dans le box des
accusés et pas les vrais responsables
c'est à dire les hauts fonctionnaires de
l'époque mais l'époque était trouble en
bidon ce qui explique peut-être pour
partie la réticence de certains hommes
politiques à l'avoir évoqué nourrissent
patron pour sa défense me dit il parce
qu'il a agi sur ordre de la résistance
que doit-on juger effectivement les
faits l'opportunisme au cynisme ce sont
effectivement des problèmes difficiles
des coeurs et ses hommes le portique
parfois aimerait éviter de voir placer
soigneusement tu le procès de maurice
papon aura-t-il lieu un jour ce serait
alors le vrai procès du gouvernement de
vichy pour la première et la dernière
fois
dominique verdeilhan
vous avez couvert pour france 2 c'est
oublié pensez vous pouvoir couvrir un
jour le procès papon
écoutez probablement pas d'abord parce
que l'ennemi de la justice et le temps
ensuite parce que ce dossier est
toujours dans un labyrinthe politico
judiciaire qui fait qu'aujourd'hui on
l'a dit et bien le dossier n'est pas
bouclé après 13 ans de procédures je
vous rappelle que pour aboutir au procès
de paul touvier il a fallu 21 ans
d'errance quant à maurice papon de se
compter il attend lui un non-lieu alors
pourtant c'est vrai hier soir après le
verdict on avait presque oublié touvier
pour ne penser qu'à papon car derrière
la satisfaction face à la condamnation
du milicien père c'est déjà un manque
les victimes se retrouvait devant un
triptyque incomplète
il y avait eu l'allemagne avec barbie la
milice avec touvier il reste le gros
morceau de nos années noires wifi paul
touvier a été jugée cinquante ans après
les faits parce que l'homme a fui la
justice en revanche si rené bousquet et
maurice papon étaient épargnés c'est
parce que la justice à son tour a été
prise de lenteur d'inertie d'amnésie
refusant de se poser une seule question
vichy est il un état ayant pratiqué une
politique d'hégémonie idéologique comme
si pour reprendre l'expression de m
roland dumas on ne voulait garder de
vichy que son antisémitisme de salon
pour gommer l'antisémitisme
d'extermination il y a une chose pire
que celle de juger avec retard celle de
ne pas juger du tout alors il est à
craindre que notre livre d'histoire se
referme sur une page blanche
merci dominique la colère de l'onu la
colère de l'otan de washington de moscou
de paris des organisations humanitaires
et même des intellectuels n'a eu
aujourd'hui aucun effet sur l'attitude
des serbes en bosnie l'hôpital de
gorazde a été de nouveau touché par
plusieurs roquettes dix personnes sont
mortes à l'intérieur de l'hôpital 12
autres à l'extérieur de l'hôpital
réaction du directeur de cet
établissement ce n'est plus une guerre
c'est une boucherie
isabelle mischler au moins 26 morts dans
la journée d'hier et 92 blessés
mais c'est difficile de faire un bilan à
cause des snipers
il n'y a même plus d'eau potable voilà
une des rares communication de gorazde
avec l'extérieur gore hd sous l'effet de
l'artillerie serbe toute la nuit écoulée
et avec une violence redoublée ce matin
plus de 60 morts seraient à déplorer
depuis hier les humanitaires pris dans
la nasse avec la population ne trouve
plus les mots ils ont décidé de faire
une grève du silence de 24 heures pour
montrer leur indignation
selon les nations unies des blindés
serbe progrès seraient actuellement vers
le centre de gore hd à la fois du nord
de yabous cas et de l'est depuis qu
patxi progression inexorable et au
mépris bien sûr du énième cessez-le-feu
signé par le président serbe karadzic a
parlé la nuit dernière
pendant ce temps à sarajevo les casques
bleus français ukrainien norvégien entre
autres qui doivent aller s'interposer
entre la population de gorazde et
l'artillerie serbe attendent les ordres
ils attendent que ce cessez-le-feu entre
enfin en vigueur
leur mission semble de plus en plus
hypothétique à moscou boris eltsine a
laissé éclater son irritation contre ses
alliés serbe d'hier le parlement lui est
plus circonspect avant de parler du fond
les élus de la douma veulent encore
envoyé une mission à belgrade
mais à washington
les décisions s'accélère le président
bill clinton a décidé d'approuver un
élargissement de la mission militaire de
l'otan
en clair recourir à des frappes
aériennes pour protéger les 6 zones de
sécurité
déclarée par l'onu à bruxelles l'otan a
confirmé aujourd'hui son accord de
principe pour prendre la défense des
populations bosniaque pilonné
actuellement à gorazde une nouvelle
action militaire contre la retirer serbe
pourrait avoir lieu d'ici à la fin de la
semaine les changes qui s'est produit
cet après midi à l'assemblée nationale à
paris témoigne tout de même de la
difficulté pour les dirigeants
politiques à prendre une décision
militaire sur la bosnie jérôme cathala
luc bachofen
que faire pour gorazde comment agir en
bosnie ces questions posées de façon
répétée par la gauche ont agité la
thrombine finale cet après-midi et le
ministre des affaires étrangères alain
juppé a sèchement répondu à certains
députés socialistes qui comme laurent
fabius réclame plus de fermeté de la
part de la france il n'y a pas de
solution militaire je le redis ici c'est
la devenez que par une sorte
d'aberration propose à cette assemblée
de déclarer la guerre et d'envoyer un
contingent pour la faire en bosnie qui
la vôtre est ici il faut donc une
solution politique
des propos largement approuvée par les
amis d'alain juppé ce qu'il souhaite et
ce pour quoi ils travaillent avec
beaucoup d'acharnement
c'est de n'être tous ceux qui ont une
responsabilité autour d'une table en
particulier les russes les américains et
l'union européenne
pour qu'une position commune soit arrêté
une solution diplomatique
à gauche on approuve également ou bien
on prend les moyens de sa politique mais
ça ça veut dire la guerre ou bien on
fait tout pour arriver à une solution
négociée sans exclure des moyens
militaires mais sans s'y limiter non
plus la question c'est de savoir si la
france et les autres puissantes sont
décidés à faire pour vraiment sur le
terrain de fermeté si oui ou non on va
lancer des ultimatums avec les moyens
militaires derrière et j'ai soulevé la
question aussi de lever l'embargo
les députés sont donc d'accord sur ce
qu'il ne faut pas faire en bosnie c'est
à dire la guerre
c'est ce qu'on appelle un consensus
minimum on le voit bien le monde ne veut
pas mourir pour gore hd mais il voudrait
comprendre philippe harrouard pourquoi
les soldats de la coalition
internationale était il parti pour
l'irak la fleur au fusil
et pourquoi sont ils à ce point barre et
c'est en bosnie oui vous savez paul pour
les pays occidentaux qui ont combattu
l'irak la guerre du golfe a eu un
avantage énorme c'est qu'elle a été sans
victime et c'est ce que veulent les
opinions publiques une guerre propre en
irak ce l'aviation qui a tout fait mais
dans les balkans la guerre se gagne sur
le terrain
il faudrait beaucoup d'hommes
de l'avis de tous les experts ce serait
un conflit meurtrier
dès le début les américains ont dit
qu'ils ne s'engageraient pas eux mêmes
au sol et leur position n'a pas changé
depuis l'effondrement du communisme
rien de sérieux ne se fait sans les
etats-unis l'onu a donc pris l'option de
s'engager en bosnie uniquement pour des
raisons humanitaires
ce qui est fort utile mais limités face
à la détérioration de la situation
l'oeil nu on l'a vu a accepté avec
l'aval de washington de procéder à des
frappes aériennes contre les serbes
en sachant que cela ne serait pas
déterminant sur le plan militaire
alors s'ils ne veulent pas faire la
guerre qu'ils fassent la paix mais
russes américains européens n'ont pas
réussi encore à se mettre d'accord sur
un plan imposé aux combattants chacun
voit midi à sa porte
et pendant ce temps la guerre continue
le peuple kabyle veut exister il a
manifesté aujourd'hui en algérie à tizi
ouzou mais aussi dans la capitale contre
tous les intégrismes politique et
culturelle à son égard mais aussi
religieux véronique taveau forcer le
pouvoir algérien reconnaître l'identité
linguistique et culturel berbère c'était
au départ l'objectif de cette marche à
tizi ouzou au coeur de la kabylie 300
400 milles kabyles ont répondu présent à
l'appel les organisations mais quatorze
ans après la répression du printemps
berbère
les kabyles ont aujourd'hui transformer
cette journée anniversaire en marche de
protestation contre le terrorisme la
violence intégriste et contre le pouvoir
en place aux cris de résistance pour une
algérie libre et démocratique
pendant plusieurs heures des milliers de
femmes et d'hommes ont défilé il faut
que les choses soient claires la masse
aujourd'hui est une marche bien sûr on
rattaque youtube pour l'aube c'est beau
la démocratie et pour notre identité
c'est une marche contre la terreur et la
violence
c'est une masse contre l'intégrisme
aussi les églises c'est l'héritier du
pouvoir c'est aussi le match contre le
pouvoir
au même moment à alger cent mille
personnes étaient rassemblées place du
1er mai là encore pour dénoncer la
violence intégriste
nous voulons créer un déclic qui puisse
permettre aux algériens qui se lever
comme un seul homme et de dire non aux
intégrismes chanson à l'intégrisme dion
ou du bas nous voulons une algérie libre
algérie démocratique
une algérie amazir des danses berbères
mêler aux youyous des femmes
alger avait cet après midi presque un
visage de fait
les habitant de vaulx-en-velin aiment
leur ville et sont allés dans la rue
pour le dire ils en ont assez de l'image
que les casseurs ont donné de cette cité
et du mal qu'ils lui font en
l'incendiant par exemple la salle des
sports reportage de patrice romdhane et
alain dupas en période de tension le
recours aux symboles a du bon c'est dans
cet esprit que la municipalité a guidé
l'imagination des enfants de vos en
plein avec leurs mots il exprime le
refus de la violence avec leur corps
l'envi de pratiquer ces sports dont la
destruction du gymnase les prive aux et
de l'asie mais maintenant on se retrouve
sans gymnase et au milieu de l'année
pour rien du tout exercice d'équilibré
en préambule à la manifestation qui a
réuni un millier de personnes et s'est
achevée par une minute de silence
on est une ville normale est une belle
ville et on n'a pas envie que ce soit et
ce quinté je dirais tout simplement
qu'il faut vivre qu'il faut que ça
s'arrête tout ce qui se passe ici et
combi tous ensemble je sais qu'il ya pas
mal de problèmes de chômage mais on est
tous passés par là en début de soirée le
préfet de région porteur d'une bonne
nouvelle
recevait une délégation de vos dés on va
commencer par les gymnases donc été
détruits
nous allons mettre 9
reconstruction rapide dans les délais
les plus courts l'état s'engage en effet
à participer aux frais chacun c'est ici
que c'est nécessaire chacun sait aussi
que c'est encore insuffisant
ces initiatives sont également destinée
à dissiper un malentendu la violence
n'est pas toujours spontané comme on le
croit elle n'est pas toujours provoqué
par des jeunes désespérés comme on le
croit mais elle peut-être délibérément
organisé par des hommes qui ont intérêt
à faire de ces sites et des ghettos pour
se livrer en toute impunité au trafic de
drogue
les autorités en sont conscientes et
prépare un projet de loi destiné à le
réprimer plus sévèrement valérie gager
février 93 dans la banlieue nord de
paris
les policiers saisissent près de deux
tonnes de cannabis à la tête du trafic
ils découvrent deux familles des petits
frères au grand-père l'argent de la
drogue faisait vivre une centaine de
personnes il avait même permis aux
trafiquants de s'offrir des commerces
comme ce restaurant bon chic bon genre à
saint denis c'est cette économie
parallèle qui prospère dans les
banlieues que le gouvernement entend
combattre
il s'agira pour la police d'abord
ensuite pour le parquet de démontrer que
des gens qui ont un train de vie
important et qui sont en relation avec
des trafiquants de drogue non en fait
aucune ressource officiel ils
démontreront par là que ces gens sont
des receleurs d'argent sale cette mesure
s'apparente à la législation sur le
proxénétisme dans le projet de loi elle
sera complétée par une aggravation des
peines pour les dealers qui utilisent
des mineurs tous les éducateurs le
disent dans les cités les trafiquants
affichent leur richesse leur belle
voiture
certains jeunes ne voient donc plus
l'intérêt de travailler à quoi bon
étudier quand on une journée de revente
on peut gagner l'équivalent d'un salaire
moyen
la tentation est grande et les
trafiquants profitent ils n'hésitent
d'ailleurs pas à employer des enfants
sachant que ne risque pas la prison à
partir du moment où des gosses ne vont
plus à l'école parce qu'ils peuvent se
faire beaucoup d'argent de poche en
faisant le guet dans un quartier en
faisant des commissions pour un certain
nombre de dealers je pense qu'il ya là
quelque chose effectivement qui
gangrènent la vie sociale et qui est
elle est guidée par un certain nombre de
gens qui sont plus vieux que le projet
de loi visant à casser l'économie de la
drogue en banlieue devrait être
prochainement examinée
par le parlement la guerre de l'anchois
va-t-elle reprendre dans le golfe de
gascogne léo lamberton et bruno girodon
sont allé sonder les marins pêcheurs
français qui restent déterminés ils
reprendre la mer demain réparer les
bateaux plus vite aujourd'hui à bayonne
les marins ont tenté vaille que vaille
de réparer les dégâts causés par les
pêcheurs espagnols
car malgré la violence des incidents de
lundi ils ont bien l'intention de
repartir dès demain et chez des anchois
nous fait commencé la seconde manche on
ne sait pas alors c'est vrai mais doc ça
c'est énorme et on ne fait que je suis
un peu près repartir en mer même s'il
faut affronter les espagnols aux abus
nous aussi on peut partir j'espère qu'on
partir vous êtes équipé un peu mieux
pour éventuellement préparent à
l'affrontement avec les espagnols ah je
ne dis pas je ne dirai pas ce combat
mais oui on les attend de pied ferme à
18 heures les patrons des douze
chalutiers agressé lundi avaient rendez
vous à la coopérative d'hendaye ont
rendu de la réunion qui s'est tenue ce
matin à paris à la direction des pêches
furieux de n'avoir rien obtenu il décide
de repartir en mer dès demain même s'ils
n'ont pas le droit de plusieurs premiers
laetitia fontarabie à face à tous ceux
qui sont au mouillage brûlent nos choix
on crève
ça c'est l'avenir
quel rôle a bouffé pas vous non plus au
niveau de la mer et le parti comme les
espagnols vous analysez pour rester à
prendre le soleil à la maison d'un poids
chin avait révoqué dérangeant rester
assis et loubet face au port d'hendaye
le port espagnol de fontarabie ya une
journée ordinaire
les pêcheurs ont ramené ce matin
soixante tonnes d'anchois le printemps
est la meilleure saison pour ce poisson
depuis deux ans un accord franco
espagnole les autorise à être les seuls
à pêcher l'anchois entre mars et juin ne
sont pas prêts à lâcher ce privilège et
demain ils comptent bien interdire aux
français du péché va se passer la même
chose que l'autre joue et peut être pire
ce sera la guerre de long chemin jusqu'à
ce qu'il y ait un deux ou trois morts
s'ils le font les français partent
d'eux-mêmes en mer à l'aube
la journée s'annonce rude bon
un cinq pièces pour 280 mille francs
c'est possible ministre du logement
hervé de charette me faciliter la vente
des hlm à leurs locataires reportage
dans le val d'oise de gens payent eux et
demi par nano vendue ce logement hlm
c'était le dernier 58 appartements était
proposé aux locataires dans cette cité
les d'orange ont pu aménager les lieux à
leur guise
ravi de rester dans ce logement racheter
à bon compte 280 mille francs pour cinq
pièces on savait déjà que c'était une
affaire exceptionnelle et dans le
quartier aujourd'hui appartement de cinq
pièces se vendront bien
sept cent cinquante mille francs si ces
immeubles avaient été de mauvaise
qualité vous auriez aussi acheter je ne
crois pas en plus il avait 12 ans on
peut y avait des choses à faire et ça a
été mon fait avant nos tranche est ici
en revanche la vente se porte moins bien
quatre ans après l'offre un tiers des
locataires refusent d'acheter
il faut dire que les loyers sont faibles
2600 francs un quatre pièces plus grave
pour les hlm
certains locataires refusent aussi leur
logement qui permet aux organismes
devant l'appartement libre 25 % plus
cher ses locataires en tout cas en faut
une question de principe
les hlm ont une vocation sociale c'est
la location que c'est pas la vente j'ai
pas j'ai pas l'intention d'acheter mais
fissures j'ai pas l'intention d'acheter
une dalle de béton qui suis sûr qui est
dégradée
donc il ya peut-être un mode de vie qui
n'est pas essentiellement focalisés sur
l'accession à la propriété
résultat la société vend à peine la
moitié des logements auxquels s'est fixé
comme objectif c'est pourquoi elle est
favorable aux nouvelles facilités
offertes
la construction a ni de france retient
beaucoup de fous et la vente d'une
partie de la fin de certains logements
nous permet de donner des éléments pour
le développement
les organismes hlm attendent en moyenne
une recette de cent mille francs par
logement quant au nombre de locataires
qui peuvent acheter leur logement hlm
il devrait passer de 2000 à 30 mille par
an
cette incitation à l'achat d'un chalet
m'a été présenté au conseil des
ministres qui a par ailleurs décidé
d'accorder une aide importante aux
harkis de france et qui a adopté le
projet de loi sur la programmation
militaire pour les années 95 2000
françois léotard a fixé le cap qui
maintient comme priorité la dissuasion
nucléaire et qui prévoit une
augmentation du budget pour l'équipement
des armées
cette loi permet en fait d'anticiper et
d'imaginer aujourd'hui les armes de
demain illustration avec laurent bouvier
et bruno girodon entre ces mirages 2000
et se creusa d'air qui se croient sur
une base aérienne dans le sud ouest de
la france il ya 30 ans d'écart et
surtout trois générations d'avions de
combat c'est en 1964 que la france a
acheté aux etats unis 40 de ses
appareils pour équiper en chasseurs
intercepteurs ses deux porte avions
trente ans après douze de ces crozat
d'air sont encore en service
ils sont vieux leurs instruments de bord
rappelle les années 60 et les quelques
modifications qui ont été faites pour
emporter de nouveaux armements n'en font
pas des avions modernes
il a 30 ans il n'a pas l'efficacité des
chasseurs moderne mais nous formons des
jeunes pilotes qui voleront bientôt sur
le rafale marine le rafale marine c'est
donc l'avenir pour ces pilotes l'avion
qui va leur permettre d'être au même
niveau que leurs collègues des marines
étrangères
l'avion qui les fera entrer dans le 21e
siècle
mais cet avion se fait attendre entre la
décision de le construire prise en 88 et
son arrivée en escadre prévu pour 1999
il se sera écoulé 11 ans c'est à ça que
servent les lois de programmation
militaire prévoit reconstruirait payer
les armements dont auront besoin nos
armées dans l'avenir exercice difficile
il s'agit de réaliser un équilibre entre
les besoins des militaires
les demandes des industriels qui
traduisent cette loi de programmation en
plan de charge est donc en terme
d'emploi et l'argent que veut ou que
peut consacrer l'état à la défense le
porte avions nucléaire charles de gaulle
par exemple devait être mise en service
en 97
pour des raisons budgétaires sa
construction a été ralentie il ne sera
opérationnel qu'en 1999
le rafale marine arrivera donc lui aussi
cette année là en attendant les pilotes
de ses crocs adhère continue de
s'entraîner sur des avions est
aujourd'hui son plus vieux qu'eux
valéry giscard d'estaing reviennent à la
charge l'ancien président de la
république souhaite que le prochain
président de la république soit élu pour
cinq ans et non sept ans c'est possible
des 95 écrit-il dans le monde
valéry giscard d'estaing s'appuie pour
convaincre sur les intentions exprimées
par georges pompidou en 73 françois
mitterrand 88 et edouard balladur
récemment jean daniel flaysakier et
didier rancoeur donne une nouvelle
importante à toutes les personnes âgées
qui souffrent de la maladie d'alzheimer
autrement dit d'une dégradation des
fonctions physiques et intellectuelles
elles pourront pour la première fois
utilisé un médicament l'attaquent rinne
une consultation du jury et prix à la
recherche des premiers signes d'une
maladie d'alzheimer la teinte de la
mémoire d'eric trois mots que vous allez
me répéter et que vous allez bien vous
tenir parce que je voulais rentrer tout
à l'heure ces trois mots ce sont 6 crew
clé ballon je serai citron traité malo
cléclé libre et qu'elle est le grand
procès qui a lieu en ce moment qu'est
terminé lagarde s'est terminée hier soir
quand on a beaucoup parlé à monsieur je
suis plus de ce qu est ce qu il avait
fait cet homme pas comme ça madame je
vous ai de délair 10,3 moore est ce que
vous vous souvenez ses trois roues pour
lutter contre les troubles de mémoire et
à améliorer la vie quotidienne des
patients atteints de maladie d'alzheimer
un médicament l'attaquent rinne arrivent
sur le marché c'est le premier de ce
genre il a une certaine efficacité mais
ce n'est pas un produit miracle
médicament n'est actif qu'en environ
chez 30% des patients à qu'il est
prescrit c'est à dire un patient sur
trois
le deuxième la deuxième limite ailier
même à sa nature ça remplace des
suppressions qui
du cerveau que ça veut dire qu'il faut
quand même des neurones ça veut dire
qu'au fur et à mesure que la maladie
avance le produit risque de perdre son
efficacité et enfin c'est une action
incomplet car ça ne remplace pas toutes
les occasions qui manquent dans la
mayenne zenner dans un premier temps là
takrit ne sera prescrite qu'en milieu
hospitalier
la prescription s'accompagnera de prises
de sang car le produit est toxique pour
le foie
c'est seulement quand on sera sûr de
l'innocuité de l'attak rinne à haute
dose que ce produit pourrait être trouvé
dans les pharmacies de ville
les écolos ont annexé vous le savez le
vert c'est pas sympa pour les autres
couleurs on peut être écolo en beige en
marron et même en bleu philippe gassot
claude sicard à l'arrivée du printemps
on vend un plein vitrine de la nature du
grand air mais aussi du vent la
fabrication des vêtements pollue souvent
l'environnement l'écologie qui vient
d'amérique veille
c'est là-bas devenu un état d'esprit est
chez nous le début d'une mode peut être
même d'un mode de vie pas seulement un
coup de pub c'est quelque chose qu'on
fait chez l'entreprise auquel est normal
qu'on a commencé à intégrer le souhaitez
dans les vêtements toutefois pas raison
et la teinture végétale qu'on utilise
cette saison s'étend avec de l'indigo on
y ajoute de la cochenille pour la
profondeur du ton et c'est bon une
chemise ordinaire c'est plusieurs
dizaines de litres d'eaux polluées pour
un drap c'est pire sauf exception et
manipulations génétiques et le coton qui
poussent déjà de cette couleur donc pour
le moment on arrive à faire pousser du
coton faire mes inventions se fatiguent
les boutons et perles du ghana des
bouteilles de coca piles et l'écologie
et humanitaire l'ivoire végétal les
bijoux d'argent extrait de vieilles
radiographies
rien ne se perd ici comme chez patagonia
et s'il avait une fibre fait à base de
donc bouteilles plastiques recyclées
ça sert plus tard allait tricoté en un
pull un pull que vous avez un petit peu
plus loin qui est un pull complètement
écologique pour nous puisque on
économise des ressources naturelles on
économise de pétrole qui sert
normalement à fabriquer les polyesters
et on encourage les gens à rapporter
leurs bouteilles plastiques pour pour la
réutiliser lorsque vous achetez un
vêtement est ce que vous pensez
la pollution qui a entraîné sa
fabrication honnêtement non pas du tout
je crois qu'on n'est pas si courant
n'est pas informée pourtant même les
grands magasins s'y met ici acea ont
garanti un coton écolo la teinture douce
et le short extrait de bois plantés à
cet effet les prix sont parfois un peu
plus élevé mais on le fait pour eux
alors faut-il hésité à suivre un
mouvement qui s'amplifie
une nouvelle polémique sur le
cinquantenaire du 6 juin 44 elle a lieu
cette fois en angleterre les vétérans
souhaite que l'on danse un peu moins et
que l'on se recueillent un peu plus
christian mary mono
cette chanteuse la mascotte des vétérans
de la dernière guerre a donné le coup
d'envoi des 500 manifestations prévues
en grande-bretagne à l'occasion du
débarquement
john mais jo a voulu y mettre sa touche
personnelle et son programme a comporté
quelques fausses notes aux
commémorations traditionnels se sont
ajoutés des concours de cuisine soirée
dansante et feu d'artifice mais les
vétérans n'ont pas apprécié ils ont
rappelé que 37 mille de leurs camarades
était tombée le jour du débarquement est
les trois jours qui ont suivi l'idée
principale est celle de souvenirs ce
doit être une commémoration pour tous
ceux que nous avons laissé derrière nous
en normandie est une action de grâce
pour nous qui avons survécu et face aux
attaques de l'opposition le ministre a
précisé l'esprit de ces célébrations
nous allons commémorer la grande et
belle nouvelle qui a suivi notamment le
retrait de la tyrannie diabolique nazis
le gouvernement s'est voulu rassurant à
l'adresse des anciens combattants il a
promis que certaines manifestations
seraient réexaminés la presse dans son
ensemble a regretté l'aspect festif de
ces commémorations et souhaitait plus de
recueillement john may d'or vole à
rassembler toute la nation comme en 1944
mais cette initiative a pris une
tournure politique avec les critiques de
l'opposition lé vétéran protesté
estimant que ces fêtes devait être
reporté l'année prochaine jour de la
victoire
et si vous voulez vous informer avant de
vous recueillir je vous propose cette
nouvelle revue pour 5 frein sur les
conflits du 20e siècle est sûr le jour j
la seule chance de médaille française
aux championnats du monde de gymnastique
en australie c'était elodie lussac à la
poutre mais la championne de france
s'est blessé à l'échauffement christophe
duchiron une dent cassée le nez
légèrement déplacé et peut-être une
fracture du plancher orbital
ce matin brisbane il y avait un peu de
sang et beaucoup de larmes sur le visage
d'elodie lussac pauvre elodie qui a
chuté pendant l'échauffement à la poutre
un agrès où le risque est présent où
l'on multiplie les cabrioles sur 10 cm
de large et le dit lui 5 à 15 ans elle
est marseillaise et c'était la gymnaste
numéro un en france elle est tout jeune
et talentueuse
à raison d'un gros travail
d'entraînement chaque jour elle est
championne d'europe junior et la contrée
sont meilleurs à gré c'est dire que sa
chute de ce matin est désolante s'est
porté par les responsables de l'équipe
médicale qu'elle a quitté le plateau en
attendant un examen approfondi sa
participation au concours général
vendredi prochain est compromise
les grandes surfaces seront peut-être
leur place sur la chaîne du savoir elles
font dans le culturel carrefour édite
des livres émotion chez les éditeurs
monique atlan georges en scène et année
avec petits pois ou une culotte ou
yaourt balzac alexandre dumas maupassant
ou victor hugo s'installe dès
aujourd'hui dans les 113 magasins de la
chaîne carrefour qui entre ainsi à son
tour dans la ronde des éditeurs de
livres de poche à mini prix avec une
recette déjà éprouvée par ailleurs il
s'agit tout simplement de publier deux
grands textes de la littérature
appartenant au domaine public dont ils
ont de droit d'auteur ce qui explique
des prix allant de 8 à 25 francs maximum
désir de promouvoir le livre ou de se
faire de la publicité
sans doute un peu les deux ce n'est pas
une mode c'est tout simplement la vente
et le carrefour de diffuser des produits
de conscience y en a des prix décalé par
rapport au marché
mais pourquoi pas c'est très bien c'est
effectivement il ya beaucoup de gens qui
viennent faire leurs courses et de voir
comme ça des plastiques affichée à un
prix compétitif que
donner des idées aux gens et le
d'acheter au receveur au score j'ai pas
le seul but vide ya je t excuse je pense
que les provinces côtières pour 25
francs devraient par ailleurs le même
prix
effectivement le livre de poche dans les
trois mousquetaires à 35 francs mais il
a ses raisons dans l'édition du livre de
poche il ya un cahier d'illustration
c'est important qu'ils aient quelque
chose de coûteux de l'impression couleur
c'est une bombe
il y a d'autre part une présentation et
des commentaires qui font que lorsqu'on
achète l'édition des trois mousquetaires
dans le livre de poche on achète autre
chose que le texte new l'intrusion d'un
carrefour éditeurs devient donc
aujourd'hui un défi un stimulant pour
les éditeurs traditionnels qui songent
déjà à la suze d'un agrandissement de
format pour réduire la pagination et par
conséquent le prix et plus généralement
à une politique commerciale plus
offensive
la guerre du livre de poche aura donc
bien lieu aux lecteurs de trancher vous
avez été très nombreux nous avons été
très nombreux à aimer le cercle des
poètes disparus sur l'auteur peter weir
a réalisé état second
c'est l'histoire d'un homme qui survit à
un accident d'avion mais qui se trouve
dans un état second
parce qu'elle défend patrick boies
l'histoire se résumant bien peu de mots
sur des images qui ressemble à celle
d'un journal télévisé
un homme sur vite un accident d'avion
mais quelque chose en lui a changé
désormais pour sa famille pour ses amis
il est devenu au mieux un étranger au
pire un malade mental
max est dans un état second j'ai
l'impression qu'il se croit invulnérable
j'ai déjà vu ça c'est ancien du vietnam
quelque chose d'enivrant en fait de
surmonter sa peur
après ils peuvent plus s'en passer max
et comme beaucoup d'entre nous il a peur
en avion il a peur de la mort et
pourtant au cours des terrifiantes
minutes que dure la chute de l'appareil
il est une expérience unique une
expérience spirituelle à laquelle rien
ne le prédisposait le meilleur mot pour
qualifier les singes max c'est l'extase
c'est un état que les pratiquants d'une
religion atteignait dans le passé où les
mystiques dans les pays d'asie c'est le
sentiment que l'âme n'est plus rattaché
au corps qu'on appartient à l'univers le
sentiment très intense d'exister beac
pour l'accident dont ce film s'inspire
la chute de l'appareil a duré 40 minutes
les gens savaient qu'il allait s'écraser
j'ai rencontré des survivants et l'un
d'eux m'a dit vous ne pouvez pas savoir
l'amour qui régnait dans cet carlingue
pendant ces 40 minutes l'amour entre des
gens qui ne se connaissaient pas entre
des étrangers c'est pour moi dans cet
amour que réside la spiritualité c'est
tous les jours maintenant tu vas sauter
dans le vide ou marcher sur des rails
pour aller au bout de ta peur qu'est ce
que tu fais quoi
qu'est ce que tu t'es déjà là on dirait
de folie c'était bien
si max se heurte à l'incompréhension de
ses proches c'est parce qu'ils se posent
des questions qu'aucun d'eux ne se pose
c'est vrai qu'on vit la vie quotidienne
comme des dieux éternel on pense très
peu à la mort
ça nous arrive que dans les moments
difficiles de la vie on a on a en a la
dimension de notre ville une vérité
vulnérabilité de notre temporalité sur
la terre
peter weir l'auteur du cercle des poètes
disparus ou de witness signe donc un
nouveau film distrayant et grave à la
fois où les questions philosophiques
affleure sous l'anecdote yan tu ne bat
pas on termine ce journal avec deux
bonnes nouvelles la première c'est le
retour demain du soleil c'est ce que
vous dira dans un instant sophie davant
la seconde celle annonçant un programme
de qualité sur france 2 ce soir avec le
retour de l'instit gérard klein
l'histoire des amants du siècle la
liaison fatale des windsor a compté par
frédéric mitterrand le dernier journal
vous sera présentée par philippe lefait
à 23h40 avant le cercle de minuit de
field demain matin gérard leclerc
recevra le couple du roi pour leur livre
citoyenne bilalian 13 heures je vous
retrouve demain soir à 20h bonne soirée
sur france 2 bonsoir